cette diversité là c'est une richesse on
m'a toujours dit qu'il faut travailler
deux fois plus fort pour atteindre
quelque chose je savais que l'univers
parlementaire et blanc trois députés
trois parcours un objectif commun montré
que les noirs ont leur place en
politique et en convaincre d'autres de
se lancer de remplir et les devoirs de
ma charge de ministre de l'économie ce
jour note dominique anglade devenait la
première personne d'origine haïtienne a
occupé une fonction ministérielle au
canada l'ingénieur marche dans les pas
de ses aînés haïtien son grand père
était député son père ministre sous jean
bertrand aristide
j'ai toujours baigné dans un
environnement très politisé mon père a
été prisonnier politique sous duvalier
toutes ces questions là était je suis à
la garderie je parlais de prisonniers
politiques
tu parce que depuis que j'ai l'âge de
onze ans que je suis impliqué dans
différentes organisations activités les
parents de la ministre n'était pas à
québec pour voir leur fille briser un
autre plafond de verre ils sont morts
ensemble dans les décombres de leurs
maisons en haïti lors du séisme de 2010
je sais que mon père est fier je sais
que ma mère est inquiète certains y est
parce que la politique c'est quand même
un jeu c'est un jeu assez actif et corsé
une joute encore largement dominé par
les blancs
quand on voit bien la chef de
l'opposition officielle la première
personne noire à devenir ministre au
québec était violent jane's
en 2007 une percée historique très
tardive si on la compare en france le
premier député noir
l'haïtien jean baptiste belley a été élu
à l'assemblée nationale en 1793
aux etats unis le premier noir est élu
au congrès en 1870 au canada il faut
attendre un autre siècle avant de voir
un premier député noir
lemkin alexander siéger au parlement
d'ottawa
le journaliste parle son gène du premier
[ __ ] élu à la chambre des communes
canadienne
huit ans plus tard l'assemblée nationale
du québec accueille son premier député
noir jean alfred moi je me sens
viscéralement fondamentalement québécois
un québécois intégré mais je casse quand
même intéressé autant table emmanuel
dubourg s'est fait rien dans le comté
fédéral de bourassa l'automne dernier
après cinq ans comme député provincial
les membres de la communauté noire quand
on les voit on pas souvent à la musique
ou bien aux sports des mois j'essaie de
montrer un autre modèle il a maintenant
six députés noirs à tahoua tous libéraux
c'est le plus important caucus noir de
l'histoire du pays d'avoir cabinet qui
est le reflet du canada dans tout ça
magnifique diversité c'est une suite est
une priorité pour moi les femmes les
autochtones certaines minorités comme
les cycles sont mieux représentées que
jamais au cabinet mais aucun noir n'a
été nommé ministre
personnellement j'ai été déçu mais je ne
suis pas fâché je pense que comme j'ai
dit l'expérience en politique est là
j'ai travaillé aussi dans la fonction
publique pendant 20 ans tout monsieur du
bourg il est important d'avoir des noirs
dans toutes les sphères de décision car
il apporte un point de vue différent
lors du terrible tremblement de terre en
haïti en 2010 mais j'avais à jouer un
rôle important pour appuyer pour aider
le gouvernement dans la prise de
décision si l'on additionne les ai vus
au parlement d'ottawa dans les
assemblées les provinces et des
territoires
il y as haut-canada 1084 députés de ce
nombre seulement 14 sont noirs c'est 1,2
pour cent or les noirs représentent près
de 3% de la population ayant n'est pas
mon conseil des ministres on s'appelle
on mais il y en a plusieurs
faut pas pousser trop loin
la représentativité la politique grecque
fergus en manche depuis qu'il est petit
il avait 14 ans quand il s'est abonné
aux procès verbaux de la chambre des
communes
j'ai toujours des frissons quand je
croise ici
c'est vraiment ckcso spécial geek fergus
et est habitué d'être le seul noir où il
passe
la photo officielle comme l'année où il
était pages à la chambre des communes
en politique cela peut être un avantage
selon lui quand il ya un policier
l'un qui se présente quelque part je
pense qu'il a tous des mises en commun
parce que tout le monde sait que j'étais
un événement qui nous on sait que j'ai
passé peut-être ils vont partir de mon
nom mais ici l'endroit était là alors ça
me donne un avantage c'est un couteau à
double tranchant parce que c'est quand
on fait une erreur
tout le monde se rappelle aussi pour le
nouveau député
si l'on veut plus de noirs en politique
il faut les convaincre de se présenter
en ce mois de l'histoire des noirs pour
mieux le connaître la contribution
historique et continue des canadiens
noirs au canada bien ma job je serai
modèle est peut-être je peux donner les
princes pire et d'autres personnes
jeunes une jeune fille ou d'un garçon de
dire si greg six professeurs moi je
préfère ça monte jusqu'à une
responsabilité de réussir pour les
autres oui sûrement
on me fit aussi la ministre anglade
c'est qu'elle est un exemple pour les
jeunes noirs qui n'en n'ont pas assez
selon elle ces modèles son père et sa
mère continue d'inspirer son engagement
mon père lui écrit à noël une carte que
j'ai retrouvées lors de l'ordre des
soeurs font le ménage
viens avec moi nous irons bâtir un
quotidien qui ressemble à nos oreilles
et je pense que l'ultime en ce que l'on
veut faire en politique c'est de
permettre à chaque personne de bâtir un
quotidien qui ressemble à ses rêves
et pour poursuivre la réflexion sur le
sujet je vous invite à consulter notre
dossier web vous voyez l'adresse à
l'autre